bei mir konkret zu ihnen kommen sie
haben einen friseursalon sie sind
friseurhandwerks meisterin die frage ist
natürlich die ich mir stelle wie ging es
ihnen psychisch während der lok downs
und wenn sie jetzt daran denken dass sie
vielleicht wieder schließen müssen also
da ist man natürlich schon besorgt also
ich bin in der vor und selbstständigkeit
das heißt ich lebe ausschließlich davon
ich muss sagen es
ist halt so dass ich natürlich mit
vorsicht an das thema herangehen auf der
anderen seite
jeder ist irgendwie ja so ein bisschen
wie gespalten die einen wollen irgendwie
wieder so ein bisschen die freiheit so
zurück ja und die anderen und so ein
bisschen
vorsichtig und ja also ich versuche die
masken pflicht so gut es geht weiter
behalten um halt zu schützen und das
auch mal kundig geschützt fühlen ich
mache mir war schon noch ein bisschen
sorge auch natürlich aus finanzieller
sicht ob das am ende dann
einschränkungen hat dass wir nicht
schließen muss das aber sie lieben das
handwerk trotzdem warum finden sie das
handwerk vollstudium sein sollte also
ich kann sagen dass das handwerk sehr
viele möglichkeiten bietet und dass man
heutzutage wirklich viele
zukunftsperspektiven mit dem handwerk
hat und dass es nicht zwangsläufig zum
beispiel nach dem abitur ein studium
sein muss sondern dass man sich da sehr
gut selbst verwirklichen kann und eine
eigene handschrift kreieren kann
und was macht das handwerk so besonders
warum erfreuen sie sich so sehr an ihrem
handwerk sozusagen alles aufbot man muss
nicht studiert man kann auch das
handwerk machen und lieben aber was ist
so besonders daran wenn man
handwerksmeister ist
ich habe das gefühl dass ich großen
einfluss mit meiner arbeit habe also
dass zum beispiel ich wenn ich eine
braut frisieren dass ich dann
langfristig auf den bildern zu sehen bin
mit meiner tätigkeit
und dass ich auch finde dass das eine
eigene handschrift hat also ich kann in
direktes feedback meiner arbeit bekommen
ich sehe was ich gemacht habe und ja
viele menschen profitieren auch davon
finden sie das wird in der politik gut
rübergebracht also dass die politik in
deutschland das handwerk auch genug
fördert und schätzt und das da genug für
getan wird vor allem in der
bildungspolitik natürlich also ich muss
jetzt aus eigener erfahrung sagen ich
hatte jetzt zum beispiel alte mann
meister gemacht hat habe schon
unterstützung erhalten also nix bafög
oder es gab viele zuschüsse ja das gibt
es schon aber nichtsdestotrotz würde ich
behaupten dass so eine grundsätzliche
kommunikation irgendwie fehlt also ich
das gefühl habe zum beispiel auch zum
thema nachwuchs finden wo holt man die
jugend von heute ab und isst man nicht
da vielleicht noch so ein bisschen in so
alten strukturen gefangen und es
vielleicht auch der aufbau der der
ausbildung manchmal auch noch so ein
bisschen in ja veraltet und dass ich
dann manchmal denke ich
habe sie ganz spannende zeit für heute
recherchiert ja ich habe mich natürlich
auch an die zeit gesetzt und das
handwerk ist im aktuellen bundestag
schwächer repräsentiert als zuvor nur
noch 44 prozent der abgeordneten haben
handwerks bezug kann man da überhaupt
genug auf diese bereiche eingehen
anstatt immer jünger und weiblicher
vielleicht auch mal mehr handwerker im
bundestag oder weibliches handwerk das
ist auch möglich hat meine tochter nach
zu bringen damit sie nicht politiker
werden muss und man ist schwarz zu
machen aber es
ist schon also mit dem handwerk
insgesamt geht ja schon gut auch in
deutschland das muss mir auch mal
festhalten ich glaube gibt über fünf
millionen kleinstbetriebe in diesem
bereich und die aufträge sind da ist
natürlich unterschiedlich ob jetzt ein
friseursalon habe oder zusagen
dachdecker bin oder erneuerbare energien
gerade mache also wir haben ja gerade
das problem dass wir die fachkräfte
nicht kriegen nicht dass wir die
betriebe nicht haben also die nachfrage
auch in der krise wird das sich nicht
substanziell ändern dieses da und was
dem bundestag angeht dass er manchmal
noch ein bisschen mehr quereinsteiger
gebrauchen könnte ist so das gilt
allerdings für andere branchen auch dass
die auswahl des ganzen immer nicht alles
nur zählt was man vorher gemacht hat ist
halt auch die wahrheit in welchen
handwerksberuf fragen sehr tochter
aktuell also die iss in zwei jahren
wahrscheinlich so weit dass sie dann
richtung vielleicht macht sondern was
anderes mal gucken ich kann sie ja ich
will sie jetzt auch nicht hier von
kaspitz war sozusagen beraten aber ich
glaube es wäre gut zu schauen also
gerade für junge mädchen mal gucken
technische berufe handwerksberufe bieten
unglaubliches potenzial dann später auch
selbstständig zu sein
und dieses klassische schema sozusagen
der frauen beruf der männerberuf das
muss man auflösen weil ich mich frage
auch oft junge leute was soll ich denn
jetzt studieren ja und ich sage mir
bevor du überlegst was du studierst
verlegt mal überhaupt optisch
studierender ist ja weil ich behaupte
mal wer heute eine ausbildung macht was
ich als fliesenleger als klempner als
heizungsinstallateur und hat noch ein
bisschen unternehmerisches talent dazu
er mit wesentlich mehr verdienen als die
meisten studenten und er ist auch
weltweit einsetzbar mit dem jurastudium
da bin ich weltweit nicht einsetzbar und
da haben auch viel zu viele von man sich
nicht so die knochen kaputt das ist ein
punkt den ich auf jeden fall von den
handwerker weiß die ich kenne mit 60
leide der körper schon spätestens und
viele können dann auch gar nicht mehr
die zum beispiel fliesenleger mal reisen
sehr harte berufe muss da vielleicht die
politik stärker darauf eingehen dass
natürlich die körperlichen anforderungen
ganz anders sind als wenn man jetzt
jurist im büro ist aber ich glaube das
hat eher was mit dem ansehen und mit dem
respekt vor den berufen zu tun ich glaub
eher der fehler ist dass viele denken
also wenn ich nicht studiert habe ja
dann ist es weniger wert als wenn jemand
handwerkers darauf ermittler breche ich
habe wirklich bis 70 arbeiten in einem
handwerksberuf mit 16 jährigen und das
fliesenleger oder maurer ist oder zum
beispiel auch dreher ist mein vater ist
feinwerkmechaniker meister deswegen kann
ich mich ja ganz gut aus würde ich sagen
es utopisch 70 dementsprechend hat das
vielleicht auch was damit zu tun
außerhalb des respekts mag auch sein ob
das jetzt primär die überleben ist für
21 dass er sagt ich möchte ich bis 70
arbeiten oder ob da nicht andere sachen
im vordergrund stehen also ich sag ja
auch nicht dass jeder jetzt machen muss
ich sag noch mal bevor du dir überlegst
was du studierst überlegt über einmal ob
das nicht eine alternative ist dass du
so eine ausbildung macht mehr geld wirst
du damit auf jeden fall also oder in
vielen fällen verdienen und wie gesagt
die internationale flexibilität viele
die möchten auch vielleicht mal irgendwo
im ausland arbeiten und da ist da bist
du wunderbar genommen als deutsche
heizungstechniker der fliesenleger aber
garantiert sich als deutsche jurist oder
bbl ist er wirklich gebraucht hausmann
gehst du hast du hast auch kinder
handwerk oder studium oder freie
entscheidung zwei freie entscheidung
zwar ganz gleich ob das ist hier auch
nicht strittig dass man seitlich in den
pkw und das eigentlich wünscht dass sie
sich so verwirklichen um den weg gehen
der für sie am besten ist und ich sie
das genau wie hier am tisch in dem fall
sind wir uns wahrscheinlich alle einig
es muss etwas sein was hand und fuß hat
und nach dem abitur muss überhaupt nicht
zwangsläufig das studium kommen da ist
glaube ich in den vergangenen 20 30 40
jahren auch immer einen fehler gemacht
worden in dem fall auch wieder von
politischer seite zu sagen wir müssen
eigentlich alle an diese universitäten
kriegen gab er die debatten darüber dass
die dass die akademikerquote auch in
deutschland viel zu niedrig es völliger
quatsch in der sie mit dem ich das
problem das ist ganz ganz viele
handwerksbetriebe gibt und sie haben das
ja auch gesagt beispielsweise auch beim
thema ausbau der erneuerbaren da fährt
und fährt und fährt es an fachkräften
also an handwerkern deswegen jeder soll
nach seiner fasson glücklich werden ob
es ein studium ist ob es ein handwerk
handwerk eine handwerkslehre ist oder
ein handwerksmeister alles wunderbar das
sind schönes schlusswort wir sind schon
beim ende der sendung dabei sind
natürlich da führte bei stoffe erst
studiert dann im handwerksberuf
glücklich geworden und dementsprechend
ist heute der schlusswort das tun was
einen glücklich macht ob es das studium
oder die ausbildung ist oder eher ein
handwerksberuf schönen abend wir sehen
uns morgen abend wieder